hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here's a left-wing lunatic saying
something completely nuts i'm shocked
about veterans healthcare
why don't you tell
tell him
[Music]
you're
you don't have to talk to the senators
to know how the budget works
i want to get this
[Applause]
absolutely i've been trying to meet with
him all the time he calls the police
officer i will we went up there and he
called the police on us john we went to
his office
we went to his office i think that was
already counted to 15
shut the
we already went there he said no he does
not want to meet him
he does not want him
[Applause]
i just got yes from one side i will go
back to the other side and i will bring
it right here will you shake my hand
you're not even an
and get something for his brand and film
it and do this all this stuff and i
don't want to put up with it so i
[ __ ] screamed at him because that's
what he deserves because he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
these people are determined and they're
not going to relent and i'm not going to
put up with that and he's not coming
into here and saying that [ __ ]
not happening thank you
this is jack fasobik i'm here with tim
jensen of grunt style and
hello jon stewart is also here jon
stewart and i have decided to come to
agreement have we not john yes sir
i lost my temper a little bit i felt
like i was being trolled and uh
i realized that the important thing is
just got to get this done for these guys
and get them over the finish line to get
the healthcare they need we're at 98
percent let's get it over the last two
percent please is that fair
you shake on it
except for five brother do or die
you